and there are you next Tuesday talking
about the 70s for Tuesday we 1855 30
here in between Family Center after fall
break on Tuesday October 25th
Magdalena's that roster from Huber's
michigan will be here to talk about
Baldwin's weird elasticity boys that she
imagined as a terrier spaces home spaces
in December
I also like today's speaker is n cabbage
and publishes distinguished research
professor of English and creative
writing at the University of Georgia in
evidence where he was also director the
ph.d program in creative writing
at the university how they just came
here for house Maryland rhythm sounded
since murders from african-american
history of life worlds is led them to
write about black music in more ways and
chocolates than one for instance is 2008
worth winners
he announced a song for halfway tells
the biography of Hathaway it's too short
and gifted like a career in verse and a
credit working progress another trend of
madness the novel and 88 their
propositions his sentence Chicago in
tuned into the Sara
of Chaka Khan in addition to his work as
a creative writer professor packages the
season and sample started his first
monograph crossroads modernism descent
and emergence in african-american
literary culture explores the complex
dialogues that shape expressive
innovation in african-american
literature but we often call by a
singular named after modernism here you
should be regarded as a double but
interrelated discourse after modernism
exemplified by a riotous lecture to
nurture brain there are Larson engaged
our interior to us it's deep into the
pinnacle of all the derive crucial
inspiration from listening to black
gospel blues and jazz music the package
emerges with to breakthrough insights in
this study first listening to music he
argues turn off it into a poet I was
relevant
talking about the experience experience
in music transform the social these are
the well I want to thank everybody for
coming of course thank professor
Goolsbee Jackie for the for the
invitation for creating the forum and
for that very informative and kind of
brilliant introduction where in which I
learned a lot about about what I've been
up to here for the last 20 years or
something like that I mean that very
seriously you know being a writer being
a writer who you know is not James
Baldwin is often the experience of
putting this putting things out into the
world and the the response to the world
can be very elusive I mean in Baldwin's
case it was very abusive more than
elusive but also very very welcoming a
very intense many writers work in this
kind of query about where does this
stuff go so it's always you know it's
always interesting
and for me always illuminating and I'm
deeply grateful for all these kinds of
responses wherever I can get them and
and so listening to that introduction is
like okay yeah I remember that and I
never thought about that but yes that's
exactly right
so thank you for that thanks for the
Frank family for I guess endowing the
the lecture series to create this forum
so you guys here we go of a few things
to say about Baldwin as a as a writer as
a lyric writer and I want to kind of
orient us a little bit toward what
that's all about
and then proceed rather surgically into
listening over Baldwin's shoulder to
songs that he himself responded to in
very precise ways so to take what songs
do I look at what songs kind of really
put James Baldwin in a room listening to
and responding to in a way that he that
we can you know we can verify and then
what kind of aesthetic cues what tech
techniques as a writer and a thinker did
he build out of those experiences that's
where that's where we're headed we'll
see how far we can get in in the in the
brief four hour period that I have your
attention all right and I'm gonna mess
with my glasses a little bit here
because I want to get into that age at
the most recent James Baldwin conference
in Paris the summer I realized belatedly
that unlike most writers certainly
unlike most writers we consider prose
writers we really do listen to Baldwin
we wait for turns of phrase we listen
and watch and read and reread again and
again almost as with our favorite songs
Baldwin's musicality is not restricted
to pieces of his writing where he
mentions music and musicians quote songs
etc Baldwin's writing smuggled the
needful reality of song onto his pages
so we read his work rather like sitting
with headphones on listening to the
textures to the rhythms to
tones of the language he's not alone in
this
but it's my contention overall that
Baldwin saw his literary song is high on
the list of musical literary work which
takes from but also adds to the music
things that in fact no singer or
musician could do and so Bowens not only
in my mind taking techniques and
information and approaches and so forth
from the music and putting them on the
page but in his pages he's giving us the
resources to more fully engage the music
itself in listening so much depends upon
one's position and what one is
positioned to do with what one hears it
is the way that tile the talk comes from
okay in the book Coltrane a story of a
sound Ben Ratliff notes Coltrane's
obsession with how microphone placements
could affect the fullness of his tone
dissatisfied with his studio sound train
said quoting they get too close to the
horn with the mics and don't give the
sound time to travel as they should
consequently they don't get enough of
the real tamp and they miss the whole
body of the sound they get the inside of
it but not the outside as well the train
said but his sound in recording after
the full body the inside the personal
questions about who one is as well as
the outside the historical questions
about what one is after that that full
dimension of Baldwin's sound my book who
can afford to improvise presented a
listening to Baldwin's writings and
speeches from shifting points of entry
the first section of that book listens
to Baldwin trying to make sense of what
his work put out there and then we
switch in the second section we listen
with him to musicians that he'd loved
very much Billie Holly Dinah Washington
and Ray Charles and then in the in the
third part of that book I'm now in the
response position of now telling you
know singing my own songs basically in
anything you can figure out how you can
figure out how all that went on your own
but that's kind of a scaffold of of
where I'm coming from here tonight
reflecting some of what I learned in
that space of that book this lyrical
approach to literary work and to Baldwin
in particular here I'm relying on a
notion of the lyric as a generally
disruptive propensity of language a
metaphorically or literally musical
interruption of the report function
often assigned to what we call prose but
what makes written language lyrical or
musical the lyrical mode bridges the
distinction between discourse language
and experience life by becoming an
experience itself the writing taking on
a life of its own in its own right a
song is discourse as experience slowing
down or interrupting the boomerang from
word to referent holding our attention
to physical and emotional textures woven
into the rhythms of the utterance itself
as opposed to looking through the
utterance like as if it's clear glass
toward what the meaning is okay so
lyrical writing kind of arrests that
that motion from what what writing what
we see on the page to what it means and
and fixes us in the in a middle position
where we're going back and forth over
the writing simply for how it is how it
sounds how it feels and then the meaning
is the product of lyrical writing then
is born you know deriving the meaning
from lyrical writing then as a process
of repeated iterations of encountering
the language again and again in the kind
of extended period of meditation from
which meanings then arise poets and
translators of course have have many
strategies for liberating language from
its utilitarian job as conveyor of human
meaning and calm and commerce but it's
Baldwin new singers generally operate in
lyrical mode better and the greatest
singers do things with language possible
nowhere else
considering language in general
Baldwin's work in particular in this
musical lyrical way emphasizes how
phrases and statements carry multiple
possibilities distinct tonality that
communicate at several simultaneous
levels that complex
that color and tamp in lyrical utterance
is one of the reasons why lyrics egg and
bear repeated attention as I said in
class today people don't listen to their
favorite song once lyrical and lyrical
entity isn't an object in linear time
like narrative experiencing the lyrical
dimension of language stirs the impulse
to listen again and again and also
requires that the artist state and
restate always in slightly different
ways with different inflections and
emphases all of these facets of language
of common to poetry of course even more
to music and intensely so in the back
black musical world of performance
Baldwin's exploration of these kinds of
repetitive lyrical textural a matter of
texture rather than textual a matter of
words he his exploration of these
dimensions textural dimensions of black
music intensified steadily throughout
his career one valuable approach to
Baldwin's lyrical power is to listen to
the way his clarity and musical
disruption deepen our sense of
collective as well as individual
elements of experience these are there
are difficulties inherent in digging
into this kind of thing simply because
American understandings of poetic
meaning are heavily laden with
assumptions that those meanings are most
powerful within people rather than
between them that is the American
understanding of the lyric tradition is
a deeply interest introspective whine to
look introspect to look within and I
argue here and you know you'll find
throughout Baldwin's work that his idea
of the lyric isn't so much a matter I
mean it is includes obviously a person's
conversations with themselves and
self-awareness but it's deeply deeply
invested in and brilliant in kind of
executing and priding scaffolds for
people's encounter with each other in
lyrical mode and therefore you can think
of this as the inter spective rather
than introspective the looking between
inter
yeah alright here's an instance in a
very very interesting book called audio
topi ins
Josh kun a recent genius according to
the MacArthur Foundation and very very
happily for Josh Koon the Josh Cunha
recent recipient of a MacArthur grant in
his book he listens to Baldwin listening
very acutely but he concludes that quote
Baldwin listened to Bessie Smith for
example and he heard himself Kuhn notes
the lyrical opening in which musicality
and language connects people across
barriers individual genders sexual
geographical generational in Baldwin and
Bessie Smith and there is a connection
such as he describes between Baldwin and
Bessie Smith and they're from different
different generations are from different
gender sex we have all that stuff it's
it's that's absolutely true
but to some degree we hear our own voice
in any lyrical utterance this is a
absolutely crucial feature of the kind
of listening that all this business
entails but in the end
Bessie Smith sound and the sounds and
black music more generally assured
Baldwin into contact with much more than
himself it figured floods families and
communities illuminated epic journeys in
his political and his political and
political content in his imagination an
important feature in Baldwin's listening
echoes what Langston Hughes meant when
he described and the introduction to
montage of a dream deferred what he
called the disc torsions
of a music of a community underlying in
transition so you know Hughes was in
montage very very very adept at doing
that same thing looking at how all this
musical business this lyrical business
really charts the territory between
people rather than just within them in
this standard kind of you know lyrical
mode this collective lyrical element is
key signals of that importance of
everywhere in Baldwin's work and just
above my head is final novel Baldwin
concluded that quote our history is each
other that is our only guide perhaps
that is what the gospel singer is
singing and it seems like that statement
is one of the kind of grand and pithy
gestures that kind of encapsulate this
whole world of of the interpersonal or
introspective lyric that Baldwin's work
is is so brilliant at exploring to
listen is very often to encounter links
between as well as within human
interiors part of the action of what we
mean when we say lyrical lives in those
links for instance in go tell in a
mountain James Baldwin's first novel
Florence the aunt of the protagonist
hears the saints in the temple of fire
baptized in the family church he hears
them sing singing standing in the need
of prayer and Baldwin writes of this
Florence quote gained again from the
song the meaning it held for her mother
and gained a new meaning for herself
okay so it's not just about the interior
of an individual this is a matter of
oncoming family relationships community
relationships such lyrical links often
turn upon repetition when Baldwin's
autobiographical protagonist and that
novel John Grimes falls on the floor of
the church at the end of the book on the
threshing floor and the final section of
that novel he falls into very literally
into the sound of the music surrounding
him at that threshold in his musical
descent Baldwin writes is kind of
tantalizing sentence quote but now he
knew for irony had left him that he was
searching for something hidden in the
darkness strictly speaking the sound is
as much experiential as musical the song
becomes a tableau in which one Riaan
counters dimensions of one's own life
and the lives of the people around them
him/her the singing and the music
provide John lyrical access to otherwise
it's unspeakable facets of his world
facets well beyond himself and here's a
passage that kind of recounts this this
communal dimension to the lyrical motion
that John's experiencing in that novel
in this cast itself back over over much
of Baldwin's work so in that novel he
writes of John hearing this music the
sound had filled John's life so it now
seemed from the moment he had first
drawn breath he had heard it everywhere
in prayer and in daily speech and
wherever the saints were gathered and in
the unbelieving streets it was in his
father's anger and in his mother's calm
insistence
and in the Viet Minh and in the vehement
mockery of his on it had rung so oddly
in Roy's voice this afternoon and when
Elijah played the piano it was it was
there it was in the beat and jangle of
Sister McCandless's tambourine it was in
the very cadence of her testimony and
invested that testimony with a matchless
unimpeachable authority yes he had heard
it all his life but it was only now that
his ears were opened to the sound and so
this is this notion of repetition you
know you can listen to this stuff for
years and all of a sudden a new level
will appear okay
in 1962 Baldwin toward West Africa with
his sister Gloria in his 1964 essay
adapted from a speech the previous year
entitled the white problem he remembered
the moment a moment of that trip and in
this essay but began as the speech he
says let me tell you a small anecdote I
was in Dakar about a year ago in Senegal
and just off Dakar there was a very
small island which was once the property
the Portuguese it is simply a rock with
a fortress from Africa it is the nearest
point to America my sister and I went to
this island to visit something called
the slave house the house was not
terribly large it looks a little like
the houses you see in New Orleans that's
the truth it got it's got two storeys
and a courtyard and a staircase on each
side sweeping stone staircases I assumed
the captains and the slavers lived
upstairs downstairs with the slave
quarters you walked through a kind of
archway very dark very low made of stone
and on the other side of you were a
series of cells with stone floors and
rusted bits of iron still embedded in
the walls this may be my imagination but
it seemed to me that the owner was still
there that I could still smell it what
it must have smelled like with all those
human beings chained together in such a
place I remember that they couldn't
speak to each other because they didn't
come from the same tribe the captives in
this corridor as I say there are cells
on either side but straight ahead as you
enter the archway or corridor it is a
very much smaller doorway cut out of the
stone which opens onto the sea you go to
the edge of the door and look down at
your feet are some black stones and the
foam of the Atlantic Ocean bubbling up
against you and here's the thing the day
that we went there I tried but it was
impossible the ocean is as vast as the
horizon I tried to imagine what it must
have felt like to find yourself chained
and speechless speechless in the most
total sense of that word on your way to
where and where is in the italics
interestingly on your way to where is
the interesting echo at the end of
Baldwin's novel go tell it on the
mountain which ends on my way which is
Amalia Jackson song I'm on my way right
Loree hallelujah I'm on my way but here
it's on your way to where and in you
know in mahalia you're on your way to
freedom land and here you're on your way
you know into slavery into the beginning
of what Western history would afford to
to black people and Baldwin ah so the
point here isn't the historians sense of
a stage the middle passage of Africans
route to the west
the point is Baldwin's musical
metaphoric imagination at work standing
at the shore of speechlessness the
threshold to the origins of black speech
of black sound he asks us to imagine
that those captive Africans were on
their way into an experience that had no
name in any existing languages they'd
they all carried languages most would
have carried more than one on to those
boats they did encounter other languages
on the voyage most of course would learn
and pass on one or more European
languages Portuguese Spanish French
English as communities took shape in the
West all of it taking Blaise Balkan
stresses in a complex position in and
often intensely violently at odds with
the modern not to say murderous the
modern mercantil purposes established by
the ways those European languages were
adapted to the tasks at hand in the new
world for Baldwin the keys to the
angular and oppositional grammar of
black speech a black English is woven
into the black music where specific
textures of black speech and song
assured distinct meanings into the words
of the English language a process that's
never stopped a version of English came
into being whose assumptions weren't
infused by what I would call the
consolations of modernity secular
secular tolerant citizens rights
individual autonomy due process all that
stuff that's in
coded in the languages the European
languages which are the currency of the
West all of that stuff of course applied
in very very angular ways to these
captive Africans that are arriving so
they're arriving in the West with no
vocabulary to process it with the need
to come up with a vocabulary to describe
life in the West without the
consolations of modernity that the West
is encoding at the same time and so you
have in Baldwin's mind starting at that
threshold you know off da car you know
it metaphorically speaking in his poetic
musical mind you have at that point the
initiation of a process of creating a
wholly not a wholly different but a but
a deeply and meaningfully distinct
version of what the English language is
is bound to describe and and and and you
know the take the the fundamental point
is that for him the musical tradition is
kind of a well black music black song
was a crucible in the formation of this
language Baldwin's best work is deeply
attuned to that history which as he said
was never written down so Baldwin's
musical mission would coexist with a
series of irresolvable dynamic
structures the core of his writing the
most resonant instance of the first
dynamic paradigm in his early career
appears at the close of his essay me and
my house published in Harper's Magazine
1955 and reprinted as the title essay of
his first collection of essays notes of
native son at that same year 1955 and so
me and my house is the first published
version of the essay that we know as
notes of native songs sure many of you
read that read this already in the class
and elsewhere so I'm focusing on one
particular moment in that essay okay and
it's a kind of realization that Baldwin
comes upon and puts it this way it began
to seem then what would have to hold in
the mind forever two ideas which seemed
to be in opposition
the first idea was acceptance the
acceptance of life as it is
and men as they are in light of this
idea goes without saying that injustice
is commonplace but this did not mean
that one could be complacent for the
second idea was of equal power that one
must never in one's life accept these
and justices as commonplace but must
fight them with all one's strength for
Baldwin key features of both acceptance
and the fight against the commonplace
were accessible in the music so so
that's the setup and I think most of
these songs
I think bear back upon that idea that to
to survive with some semblance of life
and vitality and sanity in the West
seemed a Baldwin at that moment in 1955
entail the kind of contradictory mission
where one was with one foot bound to
walk the world as it was and kind of
disavowed nothing to fully accept the
world as it's coming at you into your
experience because in various ways your
body's doing that anyway whether you
tell it to or not and so to avoid that
kind of thing that we call in in general
studies of modernity dissociation one is
saying look you're gonna have to accept
this stuff and then with the other foot
one is moving in a different direction
saying and after you accept it then you
can have at it to try to correct resist
up a pose and of course band together
with others in the effort to change the
world as it is so it's this kind of dual
and contradictory quite dialectical
feature of the way he kind of comes at
problems and comes at the the the
problems of experience the problems of
life and also the problems of kind of
recording and thinking about those
experiences and I think there's in the
book I kind of chase through that each
phase of his career comes up with a
formula of similar structure that kind
of adapts itself as he goes through and
as history moves and changes along with
him but that's the that's the basic
thing so what I want to do now is I want
to you know look with you guys listen
with you
to a series of songs that I think aided
Baldwin and you know tutored him in how
to go about this kind of a contradictory
dynamic this contradictory duty that he
was laying out for himself there 1955 so
I think what I'll do is just introduce
the song briefly play it and then talk a
little bit about the venue that Baldwin
a encountered this song in what he said
about it and then how it is that I think
one can say he took cues from it in
executing you know what he could and his
work going from from that prompt okay so
the first one here is a very famous
encounter with Baldwin and Bessie Smith
song backwater blues and backwater blues
is a song about a great flood in the
American South in 1926 I think it was
released in 1927 and you know has been a
staple of the blues idiom ever since
Baldwin the encounter we have here with
him in this song is actually dates from
1961 and a very famous interview they
did it was Studs Terkel on on Chicago
Public Radio and in the in July of 1961
actually for those of you who read the
fire next time when he's at Elijah
Muhammad's table for dinner there that's
the same week that he did this interview
with Studs Terkel and I say in the book
that I think actually some of what
Baldwin saying about his encounter with
Elijah in my hat Elijah Muhammad
actually borrows interestingly from his
conversation with studs terkel it's very
very interesting kind of thing going on
there but that's for elsewhere for now
here's back water blues and let's see if
we get this thing to play
and James P Johnson on piano can't leave
that out
Oh Gershwin
funky funky funky stuff okay so in the
encounter with ball one in this song
that we have the record of what we have
is from this interview and it the
interview begins with Studs Terkel
playing this song and then they kind of
fade in the voices they fade this the
music down it doesn't even stop the song
keeps playing and they they talk over it
the beginning of their their
conversation you can google this thing
and hear this interview but be careful
there's some strangely edited versions
of it out there but out there as well as
a full version and it's beautiful stuff
to think that this was going on on
National Public Radio and you know the
early sixties it was really nothing
similar could could possibly be imagined
today in a way but nonetheless so studs
studs terkel starts out the thing like
that he plays a song fade it down Bessie
Smith of course he says the Empress of
the blues singing of a disaster of a
flood is sitting with me hearing Bessie
Smith on this recording as James Baldwin
a brilliant young American writer but
perhaps a better description of mr.
Baldwin oh oh oh all right where are we
you know we could just huh all right a
brilliant young sitting with me here at
James Baldwin listening to this a
brilliant young American writer but
perhaps a better description of mr.
Baldwin since he was one of the rare men
in the world who seems to know who he is
today James Baldwin brilliant young
Negro American writer as you listen to
this song Jim what's your feeling and
then Baldwin comes in and says well very
difficult to describe that feeling the
first time I ever heard this record was
in Europe under very difficult
circumstances that I never listened to
Bessie in New York and what struck me
was the fact that she was singing as you
say about a disaster which it almost
killed her and she'd accepted it and was
going beyond it it's a fantastic kind of
understatement in
it's the way I want to write you know
when she says my house fell down and I
can't live there no more it's a great
sentence it's a great achievement
so the baldwin says is excuse me it's
the way i want to write but what way is
that exactly he says it's understated
you know it is is that what it's about
maybe but I'll say that what Baldwin is
hearing there is a way Bessie Smith had
attained of distilling experience in
such a way that opens rather than closes
its range of possibility without
diminishing its specificity at all so
how do you address an experience that
speaks universally to people do you
describe a universal experience or do
you ascribe or even or do you describe
one particular experience in a
particular way and here ball was
listening the belly's Bessie Smith say
the way to translate your life to the
public is not to boil it down to the
things everybody have in common
counter-intuitively it's to dig down
deep into these things you've been
through and if you can arrange that in a
lyrical fashion in such a way that it
will open back up and be universally
available without being airbrushed and
generalized at all this is counter
intuitive move it's counter intuitive
move that he actually in his um for
those scholars among you in his 1984
introduction to the anniversary edition
of notes of a native son he writes this
prologue and he describes something very
very similar to this this dynamic here
but this is years later for this for our
purposes now in the early 60s we find
Baldwin seeing this this kind of poetic
method of reaching beyond an event
without sacrificing its specificity
writing the calls for repeated readings
in which a reader places his or her self
in the mirror of the prose in such a way
that makes hidden facets of one
experience visible palpable and
clarified but altered terms this is what
the possibility of this mode seems to
allow or make make possible this is an
action that makes it possible for people
to go beyond things they accept
limitations go beyond the disasters that
they've experienced such lines for
instance as we just heard I woke up this
morning can't even get out of my door
now in Bessie Smith's
you know in the sense of the song she's
talking about the flood waters are at
the porch you know and you can't get
down the street but the way you listen
that song 10-15 times I woke up this
morning can't even get out of my door it
could describe a whole range of reasons
why person wouldn't be able to do that
depression for one despair for another
in a country which is you know trying to
process its own fantastic addiction to
opioid painkillers in the present moment
I think there's something going on at
Bessie Smith's song and that line in
particular that speaks to that what is
the source of one's imprisonment in one
in the confines of one's own life why is
it that you know people find themselves
in these in these positions in which as
she says that the at the end of the song
I can't move I can't move I can't move
there's thousands of people ain't got
nowhere to go
right okay here's a flood of 1926 but of
course this is a this is a line that
covers widespread territory in the world
in 2016 for example where there are by
by official account sixty five million
refugees officially registered in a
world never before have there been that
many refugees in the world there's
thousands of people there's millions of
people and got nowhere to go
I went stood up on some high old
lonesome Hill and looked down on my
house where I used to live and in the
South the word Hill and the word live
rhyme I think about that
I went up stood up on a high ol lonesome
he'll he'll look down on my house where
I used to live he'll yeah this is kind
of thing happens in Georgia so you know
here we're talking about a flood
knocking down our house but here we're
talking also about a person who's
achieved a certain vantage point from
which the the the circumstances of her
own life seem very distant can't get
back into the structure she's built that
her life she's found herself exiled from
the terms of her own personal geography
again a line which has all kinds of
complex corollaries for why people find
themselves in whatever position they do
to their first-person accounts of
reality similar line backwater blues and
told me to pack my things and go because
my house fell down and I can't live
there no more and again you know the
destructive force of flood but if we
think about the terms of people's
dispossession
and how that line can traffic across
history to for example a period of
American history where we had 5 million
people foreclose in their houses was a
few years ago right 2009 2010 2011 and
so that what I'm saying here is that
part of what Baldwin's encountering in
Bessie Smith the lyricist is a person
who can voice her own experience or a
version of a character's experience in a
very historically situate in particular
way that nonetheless has a massive
capacity for other people's experience
in widely disparate ways to overlap with
and so you hear Bessie Smith describing
historical location distant from your
own and far afloat but the same time if
it's lyrical language the action of the
lyric is such that the listener or the
reader inevitably also sees their own
life in some you get a reflection of
your own world out of that you know and
that's the motion that you know is that
the crux of what of what Baldwin's
affinity with the lyric really isn't as
great genius with the lyric and how one
does that is a whole nother matter but
but but what Baldwin's listening to hear
what we hear them in that interview
is the evidence of a great achievement
in those terms and when he absolutely
emulates what makes such a terrible
litany of disasters into something
people want but here's another question
that in terms of like compelling
repeated listening or who wants to
listen to a song about mass death and
floods you know but in fact that song is
a song you you know you have in your I
tune you go back to again and again
because it's just a pleasurable
listening to do is funky you want to
move you want to hear it again how does
one do that how can we account for what
joy what Baldwin talks about in terms of
the you know a lyric of disaster
producing an energy of joy
counter-intuitively what makes such a
terrible litany of disasters into
something people want to listen to again
and again well they just masochist you
know know the lyrical energy which makes
articulate the permeable borders between
one's one sense of our own lives and
another person's which makes one
person's experience overlap on to
another's creates that energy and we
want to visit instances of that
articulation we see ourselves there even
more importantly we see other people
there in ways that don't feel other to
us a lyric I say here a lyric can't be
observed one can't hear a lyric from a
distance what has to hear it as a mix of
whoever's singing whatever is being
described and also one's own voice one's
own image one's own life and the in that
in the you know the danger the mystery
the you know political stakes of this
kind of inter spective lyric are all
about that what are they overlap between
people what what are the overlaps
between people's experiences between
their situations how separate are
people's lives in fact and how do our
social discourses which talk about the
distinctions and separations between
people's lives how are they incomplete
how is there another out to what extent
is there another way of voicing all this
stuff which which joins in a
subterranean way maybe one person's
experience and and another and so
Baldwin's
introspective lyrical work and his work
in the way he goes about it I'll argue
how it gives us that sense of a fluent
traffic between us in ways that the
world's discourse is a social discourse
and even realist traditions and fiction
would you know would would would bear
against would inhibit how you guys doing
guys all right let's do
here's another okay
March 11th 1968 was a Sunday check it
out
Baldwin finds himself in Palm Springs
sitting up all night 3:00 a.m. so now
it's a Monday so that's March 12th early
in the morning of March 12th writing his
brother and sister who were living in
London Paula and David living in London
a letter while he's listening to music
and thinking about the script of the
Malcolm X movie that he's trying to
adapt ation of Alex Haley's the
autobiography of malcolm x that Baldwin
was working on a script for Columbia
studios to produce and he's sitting here
and throughout the letter he recounts
the songs going by you know and I'm
looking at this letter and I realized oh
he's listening to Aretha arrives useless
into Aretha Franklin's album Aretha
arrives 1967 out the previous year and
from the songs he's listening to side
two of that record and so we hear I'm
kind of going from song to song and
talking about what he's been up to
and the letter begins beautifully spent
the day Sunday with Brock Peters famous
african-american actor beautiful and
then he goes on and then I'll pick him
up here and he breaks in and says now
Aretha is singing I wonder her solo I
wonder
now a wreath is singing I wonder the way
she sounds is the way I want to write
you know there's something fantastically
pure and sad heartbreaking and yet
peaceful in all this horror what a
triumph to be able to sing about it to
give it back to the world to save the
world or simply another person which is
the world by making the person look at
the person oh well I'm in my I'm in the
bag my bank I meant to say I'm very high
very high because I see again again I'm
very lucky how to play my role I'm
really creating Malcolm I've hit the
keys and I'm gonna bring it off and
Hollywood is not so much terrified as
immobilized all those garbage cans and
rats and terror are beginning to pay off
I'm gonna go for broke and change this
town this country I'll be in despair
again my friends and terrify it again
and the tunnel between this 3 o'clock in
the morning and opening night will be
long and hard and black and you must
recall to me this moment this particular
three o'clock in the morning when my
courage as it will flags and my
confidence goes and my terrors rise you
must do that because this is very the
very hardest and most terrifying thing
I've ever attempted
if I fail in this I've lost my life but
I won't fail and then the parenthesis is
saying he says now I read the singing
baby I love you
now Rita singing baby I love you I deny
myself before I see you without it
sing it child so in his first book from
the 70s which would be his account of
the previous era from the fire next time
to to to the end of the 60s Baldwin in
No Name in the street name of that book
Baldwin said he intended to quote avoid
generalities as far as possible what I
am now attempting he wrote dictates this
avoidance he began the book describing
how his eight brothers and sisters
entered his life each a unique private
particularity no two babies being
remotely alike confronted what he called
this breathing miracle he continued you
begin the extraordinary journey of
beginning to know and to control this
creature and when each baby quote
without knowing what a miracle is
accomplishing exercises its lungs one
recognizes an anthology of nuance an
infinity of detail all in sound Baldwin
writes you know the sound the meaning of
one cry from another without knowing
that you know it you know when it's
hungry that's one sound you know when
it's wet that's another sound
you know when it's angry you know what
it's bored you come and go or you sit
still according to the sound the baby
makes in the end from this undeniable
'ti this intensity of nuance and the
necessity of recognition it entails
Baldwin concluded one has two choices
quote you have either grown to love it
or you have left home in his life he
would know he'd done both from this
sifting of texture from the borders of
his earliest memories even reaching back
to the time that he thought quote an
idea was a piece of black velvet in the
early pages of no-name in the street he
came upon a new paradigm of one of
recognitions the basic conflict was
between generalities to be resisted
outwitted and particulars to be
recognized according to the intensified
times the political ferocity of the age
it was a paradigm of miraculous
particularity and disastrous generality
the task was poetic one must get back to
the texture of things as
if indeed an idea was a piece of black
velvet there's more than a glance in
this there's more than a glance at the
early modernist poetics no ideas but in
things that made famous by William
Carlos Williams but but socialized to
focus on the texture and tone of people
not things Baldwin wrote incontestably
alas people are not in action worth very
much and yet every human being is an
unprecedented miracle by 1972 Baldwin
struggled with the simultaneous
necessity to as he as he wrote it treat
people as the miracles they are while
trying to protect oneself against the
disasters they've become survival
requiring the ability to recognize the
texture of particulars the timbre of
sound the create that carried the nuance
of possibility as the singular signature
as the singular signature of a baby's
cry it was almost a physical sense of
touch a willingness to be touched to be
present in the world and one had to hone
that Faculty until it could operate even
under pressure dictated by weds
widespread often lethal disasters in the
political world around Baldwin's sense
was that elite even mainstream literary
audiences the so-called privileged
hadn't honed those skills in their lives
they've lived lives largely to the
extent that they could according to the
consolations of modernity of avoidance
of those kinds of things
he knew that survival among black
families and communities had required
exactly had with the consolations of
modernity not available to them no no no
no option but to go through in or art or
1975 Baldwin wrote to his brothers
saying that all life at that moment
seemed to be quote a matter of
recognitions as usual the model was was
musical in a detailed letter to his
brother David and Paula brother Dave and
sister Paulette and living in London he
explained noting specific lyrics as they
appeared in song after song honor on
are--those album what he found was that
a rethus voice was capable of doing
revolutionary and artistic work at the
same time this as he says a no-name in
the street meant her songs addressed the
people as a whole in history as well as
the person alone in private
in one voice in one sentence it was a
collective and personal
it was a introspective and interest
introspective and introspective reality
that she had in her voice at least this
is what he's hearing okay
listening to Aretha searching listening
to Aretha searching and tender ballad I
wonder he heard the sound could save the
world or maybe it was sound that could
save one person at bottom he decided it
amounted to the same thing it was a
matter of recognitions in her Rita's
voice at once intimate and public and in
in which he heard each syllable somehow
distill the lyric personal and epic
historical modes of language Baldwin
recognized a technique that could
collapse the private artistic and the
public revolutionary impulses it was a
mode of confession a texture
cross-dimensional voice in which he
heard what he had long been after what
he had described in 1961 essay as the
power to outlast kingdoms that he
thought was black power he'd soon find
that Columbia Studios wouldn't allow him
to translate all what he heard into in
Aretha and I wonder and elsewhere into
his portrait of Malcolm X but listening
to I wonder now when here's how her
sound guides very precisely the version
of Malcolm that appears in No Name in
the street where Baldwin described
Malcolm as quote the truth about Malcolm
he was one of the gentlest people I've
ever met so how to find peace and
gentleness in the midst of all that
horror Malcolm of course when Baldwin's
writing that letter listening to that
song has been dead three years Martin
Luther King of course would be killed in
just three weeks after that letter was
written and between the writing of that
letter and Kings death they would meet
in LA Baldwin and King would in a
fundraiser okay one more you guys
the image here is from a wonderful
performance loss performance really one
loss pretty much to history between
Jayne Ray Charles and James Baldwin and
Ray's group the Ray lets in his
orchestra that was performed in Carnegie
Hall twice on the night of July 1st 1973
and this was a venue that they allowed
Bowen to reflect on the the huge
importance of the sound and technique of
Ray Charles and his work as an artist
and I'm not going to talk about that
here but I want to at least explain the
image a long chapter and that in my book
and very very interesting
performance and even equally as
interesting was the real kind of almost
violent reaction that came from the
critics to this performance at the time
well you can check that out but I want
to end here with a one song and then
maybe I'll ask for an encore I'm not
sure but the last song in Baldwin's
repertoire that I want to look at at
least is Stevie Wonder's all in love is
fair off Innervisions you guys don't
have any revisions go get it right now
you can pull out just phone now and get
it off iTunes it's classic it's an epic
it's incredible and interesting Lee
enough released one day after Baldwin's
49th birthday August 3rd 1973 but
Baldwin's birth to being August 2nd
the call to open one sense of experience
as widely as possible to accept the
world as it is you saw from 55 this was
a mode in Baldwin's life that was they
lived all the way with him too till he
died and in his final manuscript he was
working on before he died remember this
house was a memoir memoir triple
biography of his relationship to
meditating on his relationship to maker
ever as Malcolm X and Martin Luther King
and the book was never finished
the manuscript was never published but
Baldwin had some work on it but before
he you know before cancer took him away
there in the late in 1987 and in the
early parts of that manuscript he comes
upon a Stevie Wonder song all in love is
fair the call to open one sense of
experience as widely as possible in his
brilliant brilliant brilliant book white
girls Hilton Al's in that book he says
Hilton Al's irony is how we tell life we
know what it's up to
I just think I love that idea of irony
true enough but we don't very often know
what life is up to and irony in that
sense doesn't help
Baldwin assures us in beyond the way
that irony puts as it were its shoulder
in front of our chin in his uncompleted
manuscript remember this house talking
about the difference between fiction and
nonfiction but really getting at a kind
of acceptance or radical openness a
depth of how one says Amen to experience
allowing it in in such a way that he
called for on the stage of Carnegie Hall
and in the Hallelujah Chorus Baldwin
meditated on what he heard in Stevie
sound
Oh
painful cutting these songs off lyric
time is not a linear function but of
course our lifetimes are and so we move
head in remember this house here's what
Bob was thinking about with this song
the real difference the real difference
between fiction and nonfiction is that
on the stage the author says curtain and
on the page he writes the end so the
fate of Hamlet or of Anna Karenina is it
once clarified and sealed but in life no
one cries curtain and no one writes the
end and nothing can be said to be either
sealed or clarified and then here
basically quoting the song we are all in
motion toward what we scarcely know and
our lives really depend far more than we
are willing to admit on the love we are
able to give each other and love cannot
exist without privacy therefore the real
difference between this present endeavor
and nonfiction and some other one is
that I really do not know and I have no
right to try to guess how any of these
three men saw themselves judge
themselves what tormented or uplifted
them in the midnight hour what sustained
them what cast them down remains between
them and the light and the darkness they
do not belong to me in the way that
Hamlet belonged to Shakespeare or honor
to Tolstoy now this is where it gets
interesting I mean I think that's
interesting on this is where it heats up
as I have tried to indicate the relation
between an author and his people is
organic electrical and dangerous he's
talking about his characters and it is
above all a two-way street if Hamlet and
Anna Karenina
had to reveal everything in their hearts
to their creators their creators equally
had to reveal everything in their hearts
to their creations even to the
unspeakable this is rarely done in life
and when it is that moment of
and surrender enters a sacred and
utterly enviable silence then he quotes
TV a poet takes a poet takes his pen
since sing Stevie Wonder and writes the
words again Oh fair but instead Ballman
says but life is neither so forbearing
nor so meticulous so all's fair in love
means it all comes in you you in love
you take all of it and he's saying as a
writer whatever your topic is you've got
to love it in that way you as a person
and experience according to his logic in
1955 he's saying as a person in your
life part of your job in life is to do
exactly that take it all in edit nothing
because of course subconsciously and
physically your body's doing that anyway
and if your brain is trying to figure
out what to take in and what not well
your body's taking at all you end up in
this split condition all right so the
song it clearly involved in here Stevie
singing that song is is is chanting you
know stay open stay open let it in this
is if this is love
it all comes in we'll handle it from
there and so you know if if Baldwin as
he said in the creative process essay
you know if the artists war with the
society is a lovers war then that's you
know that's the gig and through that
relationship as he concluded that essay
the creative process if the artist can
do that in communion with the audience
freedom can be made real but those are
the stakes and those are the terms there
you go so you know that's a kind of
overview of a lyrical template for
thinking about Baldwin and musical terms
and then a few just kind of case
examples very very very whole particular
I hope interesting and where great great
music is functioning in his mind and
work in a way that he's commenting about
and then a person who's kind of
obsessive a little bit like me can kind
of extrapolate out from
you know find some answers in there you
go
modern meaning now I mean there are lots
the reality is that this kind of thing
is so widespread at least in my
familiarity is mostly with
african-american music and all kinds of
idioms it's so widespread the options
are almost endless it's almost as if any
song that grabs you in that way you want
to get it on thing and listen to it
again that's what's happening there and
so the power of this whole approach is
is what it is because it is not
something absolutely not something
that's encapsulated in any commercial or
private or enclosed space of knowing
this is something deeply deeply
naturalized in the culture around us in
african-american communities saturated
with this thing and in ways that
radiates into all American people in
ways that get very interesting and
complex a prevalent and identifiable so
this is a part of all of our flesh
actually but to your question you know
for me like right now I think the most
interesting singer out there is sysm sza
and she's from st. Louis you know
anybody know are freckles and big hair
yeah she's amazing I think there's more
going on lyrically speaking in the
texture of scissors utterance than any
contemporary singer I can name right now
this isn't that something is alive and
on the loose and that young woman's
voice that it comes from someplace far
off you know I really really appreciate
she's from st. Louis and I think she's
done work with Kendricks label and
toppdogg TDE Top Dawg entertainment so
look her up you can't miss the warm
winds that saw her sobriety my class in
the spring contemporary african-american
writing is named after a line out of
scissors this would give you some
indication of my regard for her her
lying out of sobriety a love of stunts
your growth
hey to make it old so we gonna do now
you know so I think I think scissors
great neo as
was telling the class before I think
it's awesome I mean Kendrick is among
the most prophetic voices in hip-hop
ever I think and I think that song of
his to be to be particularly my son is
more more more a better expert in this
than I am he's 19 but he convinced me of
this a couple years ago and I've been
checking it out and that song of
Kendrick Lamar's mortal man and I don't
know about all that stuff a Tupac and
all that business to the end but the
first three minutes the actual song of
that with his actual verses I mean you
know the ghosts of Mandela and all
that's coming and going there
it's incredible stuff you think y'all
are common ground if you promise to be
there first
hmm you know what brush do you been with
Dustin your shoulder from being offended
like how much you willing to accept the
noise coming at you in the world what
what mechanism do you use to edit your
world are the voices that are coming at
you at an angle sideways you know I
think this is this is profoundly
interesting and brilliant stuff and he's
with woven it together you know in these
incredible ways those those songs he did
live those untitled songs he did live
the one on Jimmy Fallon oh my god you
know that conversation he's has with
this African immigrant about the
comparative blues claims to the Blues of
African Americans living in you know the
projects in LA versus immigrants coming
from Syria South Africa wherever and the
way the African voice the South African
voice I take it to be and that in that
conversation is kind of saying you guys
you know you think you got a rough
incredible what have we ever heard that
before
you know in popular music the kind of
diasporic conversation comparative blues
it's amazing so I mean their honor their
black copy of music right now is in is
in great great great shape and great
hands and we've lost you know we've lost
we lost here recently
Whitney Michael and Prince in my lyrical
mind a Malcolm Martin and Medgar and I
hate to say but Whitney Michael and
Prince there's some strange parable
going on
and I think of those three performers my
generations greatest performers dead all
dead all killed by I say all dead by
they're beholden to behold in
relationship their addiction to killers
of pain that's me
so deep you know but but uh that's why
african-american lyrical the
african-american tradition of vitality
and lyrical utterance is in no way the
property of any record label is in no
way the property of any star any Super
Bowl halftime show it's bigger and far
more widely dispersed than that so yeah
now I'll say one more thing I have this
YouTube I have this um Facebook clip of
this couple singing I can't make you
love me
anybody see this on Facebook in the last
like month this black couple and they're
in their house doing a karaoke night and
their kids are run around in the
background and they're in there singing
I can't make you love me even if nobody
see that you look up my facebook page
and go on my timeline down you'll find
it it's awesome you know I can't make
you love me if you don't you can't make
your heart feel something that won't
this song of breakup but they're singing
a song in this incredibly loving way and
then a Donna meet know they're saying
that whole business about I can't make
you feel something you won't to the
camera just saying that to to the United
States not to each other you know we got
this handled we can't make you feel
something you won't we can't make you
love us if you don't and again there so
that was my ending but that incredible
duality of private and political of you
know how these things speak in
simultaneous ways to different audience
is in this couple whether whatever they
have on their mind I don't know but you
watch that thing and tell me I'm wrong
and that's what a counselor is just
mesmerizing power plus the fact that
kids are in the background and the
little guys trying to sing a little boys
bring him a picture he wrote he's like
you know it's a later kid you know it's
uh it's great
mmm
interesting
I love the photograph I don't have that
much to say about it I it's like I say
that this is a performance totally lost
to our history and if you if before this
book of mine if you were interested in
looking at this performance involved
when I Ray Charles did there was
literally nothing written about it after
three days later when reviewers had
their say in the New York Times and
elsewhere and so I think when I found
this book I found the script of that
performance the fact I found Baldwin's
Brothers script of that performance lost
in a box in the Harlem in the Harlem no
in the Harvard archive and that was this
amazing recovery and then I looked
around and found this found this guy in
Denmark who runs this website on Ray
Charles and this guy has every single
thing that's ever had anything to do
with Ray Charles on his website I think
it's called the Ray Charles video Museum
or something and he had this photograph
and I was you know he was the the
sensational discovery was such that I
thought it was a good way you know here
is Baldwin in musical performance you
know was one of the music's meant the
most to him and aesthetically I you like
you say I like ones in the dark ones in
the light I love the balance between the
gingham on both sides and I think it's
like it's a great photograph I don't
even like the kind of strange angular
array of the mic stands going on in
there between them I dig it
I like to look at it I had another one
remember Phoenix of Baldwin outside a
barbecue spot in in Durham North
Carolina which is it equally is
brilliant compas more brilliant
photographic composition than this one
but yeah
No